it's a sea of mud with the flood water
beginning to recede the devastation it
left in its way is starting to emerge
a city known as the Ceramics capital of
Italy is now covered in a thick layer of
sludge
wherever you look people are shoveling
and scrubbing trying to recover its
colors and art
but much has been lost forever at the
18th century manfrediana library at
least 10 000 books have been destroyed
there is no way to salvage anything in
these piles thankfully most of them are
fairly new the ancient manuscripts and
rare books being on the Upper Floor
still Daniela simonini is perplexed
the water was violent it arrived with a
huge force and in just a few minutes it
engulfed everything shops it destroyed
lives it's really really scary because
one doesn't expect this from water water
is a friendly element but it can also be
deadly when it arrives so violently
fences known for his glazed earthenware
known as FiOS coveted by Europe's kings
and queens for centuries a tradition
that continues to thrive today says
Monica zawuli she manages a museum
collecting her father's Carlo sculptures
and other works it lies in tatters
the water seeped in absolutely
everywhere in the city not
discriminating between past and present
public or private this actually used to
be an exhibition room just a few days
ago now all you have is a puddle of Mud
mixed with the clay that the artists
used to use
the Clay comes from the hills
surrounding the city that's what made
Carlos zawuli famous worldwide
this water didn't just erase my past and
the memory of my family we had left the
studio as it was many artists came to
work here from all over the world many
of the artworks were destroyed and we
won't be able to find the fragments
because the math is so dense it's
impossible to sieve through it
a sentiment shared by Carmen sassy she
creates the work of her late husband
evil kept in a desecrated Church 70
years of sketches tukas and gestures
remain underwater she has no idea if any
will be salvageable is the story of
everyone in fayenza piles of past and
present are everywhere waiting to be
removed ironically a city that thrived
because of its Earth and Clay was also
brought down by its own riches
just how bad is the damage is yet
unknown HUD Abdul Hamid al-jazeera
fianza and Emilia Romania